- I think we have a title.
Yes...I wore a suit.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you this was the
last Monday
morning of your life?
8:30 in the morning.
Good workout this morning,
got a little extra
sleep which was nice.
Headed to the
New York Stock Exchange
doing a network show.
A platform called
"Cheddar by John Steinberg"
former number two at Buzzfeed.
Kind of an OTT, mobile first,
CNBC for the Millenials.
So I'm excited about that.
It should be good then I'm
going to a Rezy board meeting.
Rezy being our restaurant
app that is kind of like an
OpenTable competitor.
It's doing extremely well.
Lot going on there so big new
partnership with airBnB so going
to have a big meeting there
Ben Leventhal, the CEO,
and Mike Montero, the CTO and
Matt Higgin from RSE Ventures,
my partner in Vayner/RSE.
Great dude, you saw him
in the Portugal episode.
And then just
some more grinding.
Couple more board meetings,
a curriculum meeting.
I'm doing a bunch of
live streaming today.
Also announcing
the 60 Second Club.
Just should be good day.
A little gloomy and then
Monday Night Football.
My New York Jets versus
your Indianapolis Colts.
I'm gonna start doing more live.
Just in general.
More live, DRock.
- [DRock] More live.
- [Gary] More live so
that's what we're doing.
We got a little mic thing here.
It's pretty cool, huh?
- Yeah.
- So like if you're not
too far away it'll work?
- Yeah.
- It'll be interesting,
obviously DailyVee is edited so
when I'm doing stuff
that can't be heard.
I'm not sure what it's going to
look like to really go live and
have somebody
following me around.
There's gonna be a lot of
weird, "Dunk, get out of here."
It's gonna be awkward but our
ambition is do quite
a bit of live today.
See how it works, see what it
feels like, see what you guys
think of it and so
that's what we're doing.
I have to work so I,
Dunk, you know,
we'll just try our best.
- [Eliot] Best advice
for a young man?
- To understand that he's a
young man and he is a shitload
of time and his behavior should
be predicated on the fact that
he lives for 80 more years not
eight more weeks and so when
I talk about patience, one of
the things that I don't go into
depth on is the fact that
it's practical, it makes sense.
If you're 22 and you want it
now, now, now you're doing
behavior that's gonna hurt
you often in the long term.
It's just a pull and a tug.
It's very rare for behavior to
have both short and long-term
benefits and there are those
things and they happened but
when you have a long-term
mindset, you're actually being
very practical and that's what
I want young men and women to
understand is that and even
30 and 40 and 50, I've been
noticing a lot of 30, 40,
50-year-olds saying,
"What about me?"
What about you?
You have 30, 40 more
years if you're 60.
You know, of course you have to
assume that you can get hit by a
bus tomorrow but the truth is
if you really thought that you
would be so rogue, you
would do such rogue shit.
Do you know if somebody told
me I'd die in two days what,
I would go off the deep and
I would do the
craziest shit of all time.
- [Eliot] What would you do?
- I definitely run naked on the
football field today
at the Jets game.
(DRock laughs)
That's for damn sure.
That's 100%.
Exactly, exactly and
so then he said
you're the number one firm
on my list right now
so I'm gonna narrow
it down and then
make a quick decision.
I think we got him.
- [Eliot] How much
sleep do you get, Gary?
- I get five, six or seven.
Five, six or seven.
Yeah, I get more
than people think.
Sleep's important.
Guys, it's not how
much sleep you get.
It's what you do
when you're awake.
That's the fucking shit.
DRock, do the little quote thing
so they can still shoot that.
We need to do more
of that in DailyVee.
Tyler, more of that in DailyVee.
Good quotes,
turn them into shit.
Right?
- [Eliot] Yep.
Okay.
Are you guys able to come and
see me in Chattanooga in 10 or
11 days when I'm gonna be
there for the holiday party?
Can I get you and
Tyler connected and
maybe we can do like a...
We're not gonna accomplish much
here on the phone 'cause I'm not
good in phone structure.
But I'd love to get together for
a coffee or a drink and
really have a conversation.
Truth is I have a
lot of thoughts.
I mean it's even been with
VaynerSports going
so well I'm like fuck.
Am I five years away from
Vayner(censored), you know?
Especially, Vayner, I'll be
very frank with you I think
VaynerTalent is gonna
really, really, really work
and so yeah
it's probably a very good time
to have a real conversation.
- [DRock] You want to end it?
- [Gary] Yeah, I want to end it.
- Use this mic.
- Okay.
Hey guys.
Good thing to do is hit me up on
Twitter on things that you got
out of this stream just now.
Here's a good one, he me up on
Twitter Gary-V-E-E and give me
your 140 characters on what else
you want from this live stream.
We're gonna really
try to bring more value.
Just had a great
VaynerSports talk,
trying to close
an incredible kid.
I want him bad.
Rezy now, just had a great
call with a Nashville
music organization.
Some good stuff brewing there.
Trying to keep you
guys up to date.
See you back at 2 o'clock
on live stream on Facebook.
Love you.
See how happy he was?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- [Gary] Nice dude.
- Live is so important.
- So important.
If we don't get this kid,
I'm closing the firm down.
(DRock laughs)
- [Ben] Hey, what's going on?
- [Gary] It's good
to see you, man.
How you been?
- [Ben] Good to see you, too.
You're all dressed
up, what's going on?
- I did Cheddar for
Johnny today and so...
- He finally got you on.
- He finally, he won.
Is this Higgins office?
- [Ben] Yeah.
- [Gary] Okay.
I'll do it there.
I'll see you in a little bit.
Hey Simon, it's Gary.
Let's take a step back because
the good news is with all intent
I want to continue
this relationship so
I feel good about that.
So let me just hear
this right, we write,
you know it's interesting,
by the way Hollis?
Is that the book that I think
I'm setting up to write the
most after "Crushed It!"
is "Perfectly Parented" which
is like a business book
really about parenting.
Just had a super constructive
conversation with my lawyers and
my publisher HarperCollins
and we should be on our way.
"Crushed It! How these
seven," actually this is a good
opportunity, let's
actually start this right now.
Do we have an email
that we want to send?
Let's set up an email.
CrushedIt@vaynermedia.com,
can you hit up Andy
or Tyler right now.
CrushedIt@vaynermedia.com
if you have a
legitimate story of how
the book "Crush It!"
impacted your financial career,
how you build your brand or
your business because of it and
the financial impact around it,
the book that I'm coming out
with is gonna be called
"Crushed It! How these 49, 57,
133" depending on how many of
you know this, how many of you
tell us your stories and they're
legit and you made legit money
and you did it the right way,
the way I care about it,
"How these 130,"
no $17 e-books on
how to make
Instagram hacks work.
"Crushed It! How These 137
People Crushed It and How You
Can Too" and so then I'm gonna
to basically rewrite "Crush It!"
in a 2017 way
and really talk to
people to how to build their
brand and how to build a
business on Facebook, Twitter,
YouTube, Instagram, Snapchat,
Pinterest, LinkedIn and then
talk about emerging things like
House Party and Marco Polo
take some risks.
That'll be in the back.
'Cause they may not
be around long-term
but really talk
about what's changed
in last nine years
since "Crush It!"
came out or eight years and a
lot but really if you look back
at that book the the reason
it's been timeless is
I was right and
it's still right.
Obviously, there
are some nuances
and different platforms
that people can use,
some of the apps that
I talked about in that book
aren't around or pivoted but the
thesis is very true which is
this is the greatest era ever to
be an entrepreneur because the
internet is the middleman and
the cost of entry is zero and
you can really
build real businesses.
Little Dunk from Sweden, real
player off basketball dunks,
I mean come on.
Life, it's good if
you're willing to hustle.
("Jump Off" by Fiifi Jr.)
We're just fucking going for it.
(DRock laughs)
Today.
- [Eliot] You live?
- We're just all-in.
Yo, what up Periscope?
Thank you, Derek.
I am suited up today.
Looking the part.
- [Eliot] Are you gonna change?
- I'm gonna change but you know
I'm thinking about maybe going
suit now for like a year.
- [DRock] I like it.
- [Eliot] A year?
- [DRock] I like it on you.
- Yeah. I think
I should just go suit.
- [DRock] Do it for
a month in January.
- Yeah, just
January is suit month.
And then give all
the suits away to the
- [DRock and Gary]
60 Second Club.
(DRock laughs)
- Guys, actually let's see how
well we've been promoting for
the last 12 hours about
this new exciting thing.
For the 670 of you, how many go
yes, no in the
comments right now.
How many of you know
about the 60 Sec Club and
how many don't you?
Say yes or no, go.
Yes, yes, no, no,
yes, yes, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, good.
For a lot of you that're no's, a
good amount of no's I'm excited
I brought it up.
Go to my Instagram,
go watch my story.
Go look at my post two or three
posted ago, one or two posts
ago, you should deftly
turn notifications on.
You 100% want to turn
notifications on on my
Instagram account, I'm
starting something in 2017.
I'm setting it up now.
All of 2017 I'm to be
doing random giveaways to my
community, tickets to concerts,
20 minute phone calls with me,
signed books,
early access to stuff,
free tickets to my conferences,
I just want award the
people that give me their
attention and care enough about
me and so I want to just, I also
like games and competitions so
the 60 Sec Club on Instagram is
people that comment and like in
the first minute of
an Instagram post.
So that's why you got to turn
on notifications so you see it
comes in and most posts
I'm going award
one to 10 to three,
you know, very random, I'm a
random character probably gonna
put Dunk in charge of it.
We haven't really
fully talked about.
It's a lot, it's gonna be work.
- [Eliot] Yeah.
- Two or three posts a day,
give it away, logistics,
getting people's email.
We're probably gonna,
actually you know what?
I'm gonna get an intern, getting
a full-time intern for all 2017
to be the logistics
person of the 60 Second Club.
So, let's put this in to
DailyVee if you're
seeing it now.
She or he is gonna be selected,
yes, I think you have to win one
of the 60 Second, yeah actually.
Hit up Chris and we need to
make a piece of creative for
Instagram to who's gonna be the
intern of the 60 Second Club.
Lot of me's going on right now.
Good way to get in
to my inner team.
This is the fastest, quickest
way to get inside Team Gary.
That would really throw
everybody for a loop if I wore
this to the game.
- [Ben] That'd be funny.
Are they home tonight?
- Yeah.
Monday Night, home, tonight.
Yeah, I might just
do it in person.
Yeah, we'll see
what it looks like.
Don't keep it as a call.
We'll do it as a in-person.
Alright.
Good, we'll see you
in 10 minutes then.
I'm going in with Tony now.
Okay.
- [Man] The suit!
- Yeah, wow, huh?
I don't know who I am either.
This is rare.
It's rare.
Yeah, that's what I figured.
How are you?
- [Man 2] Fantastic.
- [Gary] Great, real pleasure.
Thanks for being here.
How's it going?
- I've been watching for about a
year and a half so I know your
opinion of college and
university and what you went
through and everything.
And so I'm trying
to bridge that gap.
- [Gary] Sure.
- You may think it's foolish or
whatever you want to call it to
go to university
in the first place.
- [Gary] In a very
narrow way. Right?
I want to make sure and
spend more time
on clarifying my college.
The current curriculum
for entrepreneurship
and hard-core marketing,
I think,
is flawed to the marketplace.
So I think that there is,
there's two ways
to break this down.
There's the practical and
there's the ideological and so
like the practical
answer is nothing.
Nothing has to change, we
continue to hire all these kids
and so will everybody
and that's just the punchline.
And then we actually, I can't
speak for everybody here, I,
Gary, actually just default into
you're coming with nothing and
we'll teach you and then I
can afford that and we built a
culture and have infrastructure
that will do a good job of
getting you up to speed within
a six or 12 month window and
that's the punchline.
So the real question is
what conversation
should we have here?
I guess your selfish point of
view here is how do you let your
students in your university have
a disproportionate edge on the
marketplace so that it's known
as the place that's kicking out
these kids so that every firm
that has to follow our model to
be successful going forward.
In that way the answer
is practitioner-ship.
Truth is as long as they pump
out your system where they're
able to be a practitioner,
I don't care if 101 and 201 and
301 was playing
volleyball as long as
401 was practitioner-ship
and they could
come out and do it.
That's how you'll win.
So to me the good news is the
hoops you have to go through are
not a dealbreaker by my stretch.
It's just when they pump
out if they can do,
you're in a totally place.
Yo. What's up guys?
This is Mike Boyd.
- Hey.
- He's good with music and shit.
- Thank you,
thank you, thank you.
- No, fight.
If it dies, it dies.
- [Tyler] Cool.
(clicks tongue)
- [Gary] Okay.
Good to see you.
Thank you, brother.
Please tell me you caught that.
Please tell me you got that.
Did you get it?
- [Eliot] Yes.
- Yes. That's what happens.
Are you live?
You got to talk to them.
They'll get bored.
Right guys?
Dunk, you can't just be
like, you're not DRock.
You're Dunk, you can't
just film we walking.
That's some boring ass shit.
Great.
Hey Jack, how are you, brother?
("Can't Get It Out"
by Fiifi Jr.)
It becomes a classic upside
versus downside
execution, right?
And there is clearly the
downside of where the momentum
of the conversation could go and
so I have empathy for that point
of view on that.
- [Man 3] So, we're
gonna talk about 2017.
This episode's
going to be futurist.
- [Gary] Yep.
- [Man 3] We'll talk
what's coming next.
Starting with CES where Pat just
first learned about
you last year.
What do you see for 2017 at CES?
How does that start?
- You know it's funny.
Especially 'cause I know a
lot of people are just learning
about me right now.
I'm not Nostradamus. Right?
I love people that
think I am but I'm not.
You never know, just what
I think I'm good at and what you
probably seen the last decade
is when I taste
it I'm like a shark.
Sharks are crazy.
A little, like a little--
- [Man 4] A mile out.
- a mile out like a, like a
little speck of blood and
they're like pfft.
That's what I'm good at.
When I feel that, when I taste
that blood in the water
I'm so fucking on it.
It's 24, I shut down in December
on my family vacation and
spent every minute
dissecting Snapchat
'cause I knew Khaled had popped.
I'm like wait a minute if
Khaled's popping this is really
double good for me because
the way he rolls, that's kinda
similar to like, we got our
differences, but like the thing
that the kids are attaching to,
that motivation like I'm like
I'm living that.
- [Man 4] Right.
- For real.
I'm only do that.
I don't "and DJ," that is me.
That is what I do and so I think
that that's what I'm
paying attention to.
I don't know what's next but I'm
always circling those waters and
don't let somebody drop a little
ounce of blood 'cause I'm going
24/7 at it once I taste it.
Of course.
I always react to
what's around me.
- Exactly.
- I almost made a star
basketball reference.
("Low" by Fiifi Jr.)
We know that.
100%.
- 'cause I met with the
underlings and then...
- Call it what it is, here's my
pitch very simply and 'cause you
already know it before
I even get to say it.
There's no way in fucking hell,
none, that you're spending that
(censored) million dollars in
marketing better than we would
spend it for you and you get
the upside of building your
relationship with me.
It's a complete no-brainer.
Now we just got to
figure out if we can do it.
- [DRock] What advice would
you give the highly
regulated industries--
- Time out.
I want you two, I was gonna
forget this, I'm gonna put out a
call to action for somebody
to give up their
winter break and hustle
and so I want a kid,
I'm gonna pick a kid and
we're gonna document.
I'm gonna FaceTime and help
the kid go and shop on eBay,
you're gonna go back to their
house, we're gonna film them,
post it, and the video is
basically how he made
$337 during his
winter break instead of zero.
- [DRock] That's a
really good idea.
- In thesis...
- Yep.
- Pretty good day so far.
- Great day.
- DRock, this is, come on.
(DRock laughs)
No, I want you in it but
just don't want you to talk.
- [Tyler] Is DRock gonna ride
with you to the airport?
- No, I can do my thing.
- [Tyler] Cool.
- Now that I'm a filmmaker.
(DRock laughs)
- Izabella with a "z".
- [DRock] Vlogger.
- DRock, if I wanted to be a
fucking filmmaker I'd be the
best fuckin' filmmaker
on fuckin' five minutes.
Just so all of you know.
- [DRock] You think?
- I know.
I know Vincent.
- There's the guy, Lance.
- [Gary] I had email back like
13 people in comments saying
"No, I missed that
meeting with Vince."
I didn't want to bullshit them.
- Yeah, definitely.
- But how about
the holiday party?
We can hang at the holiday par,
before the holiday party, right?
- Yeah, I'm here.
- Alright.
- Cool.
- I know you won't forget.
- I won't forget you.
- I know you won't.
- Might be turning up.
- Alright, I feel like I haven't
talked to you in like 100 years.
(bell dings)
- I know.
- I don't even know
you really at all.
You look so good with your hair.
- [Staphon] You look
so good with your suit.
- I know.
I get it, I get it.
("Drake - Ish" Fiifi Jr.)
Yeah, that's where all
my focus is right now.
I've reviewed some
stuff over the weekend.
I have some stuff coming
with Darren this week.
Later in the week.
Straight.
- [Man on Phone] Our
(inaudible) 2.0 product.
- [Gary] You're gonna go
left not here but the next.
You know the classic, changing
in the back of the car for a
Jets game while
you're on a board call.
You do that, right?
- [DRock] Closing remarks.
- Yeah.
Live here in the Meadowlands
in New Jersey, East Rutherford,
MetLife Stadium the Jets
take on, just kidding.
Love you guys.
Hustling, Jets game, might even
go to another meeting tonight,
I'll update you.
I'll try to get some
B-roll for you DRock.
Just a solid Monday grinder.
Bunch of good meetings.
A little Hot 97 and
I wore a fucking suit. See ya.
Seven minutes into the game the
Jets are losing 14 to nothing.
Alright, this is Phil and Andy.
We sit together at every game.
I poke Andy to get up
for every third down.
Phil sings the best national
anthem in the entire stadium.
What do you have to
say for yourselves men?
- Go Jets!
- Let's try again.
- And again and again and again.
("Drake - Ish" Fiifi Jr.)